you retired then you came back then you
retired again
do you think you might un-retire a third
time would you give it another shot or
are you done done
done hey if
if the situation is right then yeah i
mean it could happen
yeah but i mean i i've been uh
let me see i've been asking questions by
a couple teams
yep here recently right like are you
ready
i'm ready if y'all super bowl ready
that's that's what
that's what it'll take me to come out to
come and play
again yeah it'll have to be a guaranteed
super bowl
game for me really okay
okay yeah you know it's funny you say
that because that's my
no you didn't let me that is my i say i
will
because i get asked
look don't laugh i am a very talented
athlete
and how do you think i do in the nfl
marshawn be honest how long would it
last uh how long would you last
yeah i'll tell you like this if you came
and
suited up went out there
and played defense db
i think if you did that little hair whip
that you've been doing with your hair
yeah i think you will plus i think you
will bust a whole lot of heads
yes now you might get penalized to cut
you might get penalized a little bit but
i think you would bust a couple heads
with that little move right
right that's what i do and this is what
i fake them out
i go this way i go that way they don't
know where i'm going
they're looking at the hair they're not
looking at me because the hair doing
like this